numbers and words by grace Sherman is
about a young black mathematical genius
with the potential to make all the most
important discoveries in the field as he
struggles to hold on to his gifts while
spending decades of his life in prison
Marcus is an outsider even in his
advanced calculus class where he's only
one of two black students in this scene
on the bus home DeMarcus is approached
by the other student young Beth together
they debate his love of mathematics with
Beth love of literature interior busts
day the market starts writing a math
problem on the bus seat why are you
always writing out math problems like
that I'm trying to figure something out
what Athenian hypothesis one of the
oldest problems in mathematics all past
attempts to solve it have used a metric
tensor but I think they're gonna be a
different approach each problem I write
helps me build that approach how long
have you been working on it since I was
seven he goes back to writing on the
seat you're vandalizing public property
I don't have any paper that pulls out a
notebook decorated with glitter and pink
ponies on the cover
proudly hands it to DeMarcus DeMarcus
disgusted by the pink ponies tears off
the cover and tosses it on the seat
starts writing out a problem the
ultimate boon what miss Andrews is
teaching us Campbell's the hero with a
thousand faces you would know it if he
ever came to class in every journey the
ultimate boon is the great reward of the
quest what the hero wants on the journey
for in the first place well what would
be your ultimate reward for working out
the hypothesis a verified proof fame see
it's all it's all their stories
mythological [ __ ] it has no bearing
on us
I know damned journey what what is
important is real it's concrete it's
logical properties that can be measured
and are universal not stupid fantasies
up to mostly white people's
interpretation of if they are relevant
or not reading is that fruitful miracle
of a communication in the midst of
solitude house
mathematics is a more powerful
instrument of knowledge than any other
that has been bequeathed to us by human
agency discard Asst stories of
imagination tend to upset those without
one project Markus hides a smile there's
not a few sheets of paper than write
some math problem in the notebook gives
it back to bethe here a little integer
work on solving this it uses Euler's
formula the most beautiful narrative you
will ever lay your eyes on best stares
at the complex problem DeMarcus goes
back to his math why does it make me
weird just for wanting to save an owl
because you ain't some little white boy
who lives on a farm in damn Saskatchewan
exterior Street day to mark you some
best step off the bus
bed and Beth and mid-conversation it's
the most informative book on sea turtles
ever written I mean did you know that
female sea turtles go onto the beach and
dig a body pit in the sands they can
nest I've always wanted to see it there
they're endangered partly due to dirty
beaches did you know that Marcus Starks
a walk in the opposite direction
um can you can you walk me home
go away kid I've got things to do I will
give you $5.00 I said scram damn pests
the Marcus walks away
Beth nervously looks at a group of
unruly teenagers down the corner smoking
and drinking she reluctantly makes her
way past them they begin with the cat
calls as hey what's going on girl my man
want a holler at you
teenagers burst into fits of laughter
Beth ignores him as she struggles to
walk with her heavy backpack holes
untied her to her jar of crawly things
what are you got in that backpack it's
holding you down sweetheart I think it's
them glasses man
damned a mrs. big [ __ ] nappy-headed
ugly ass [ __ ]
[Laughter]
even more fits of laughter death tries
to walk faster on DeMarcus as he stops
walking I said come here [ __ ]
Beth keeps walking a rock flies through
the air hits her hard in the shoulder
Beth starts to run the leader chases her
catches her by her heavy backpack and
throws her hard to the ground goes in
for a kick when POW demarcus lands a
hard punch to his face and he falls to
the ground he scrambles up gets into the
mark as his face won't do huh what could
you go what you wanna do you don't want
it you don't want it something into
Marcus's eye tells the boy he should
walk away he makes his way back to his
friends who have not moved an inch from
the other side of the street to help
demarcus helps best stand up she holds
on to her surprisingly intact of jar of
crawly things blood drips off of a deep
cut on her chin he wipes off some of it
with his sleeve
give me this
you know her heavy backpack onto his
shoulder what you got in here integer
every book ever written they walked they
walked towards the apartment building
thank you
I'm only doing it for the $5
[Applause]